many parents heading back to the office
there's now really a high demand for
nannies and babysitters here in the
valley sally jaramillo spoke to some
local moms and the owner of an agency
about this and sally a business
apparently is really booming
nannies and babysitters are extremely
needed right now and although rates are
higher than what they used to be in the
past years parents say they simply don't
mind pain when it comes to their
children
significant need for help with the
children and then going to regular lives
and trying to get also as a small
business owner trying to get my business
back on track jessica peralta is a
mother of four all between the ages 5
and 11. she is the owner of fit for moms
and says finding a sitter is hard these
days so it's a matter of you know trying
to do research and finding others in the
community that you would entrust with
your own kiddos sarah cook is the owner
of nannies and grannies a 24 child care
agency in las vegas who has been in
service for 35 years and says times are
changing we are on the phones 24 7. the
town is booming people are ready to
travel again people are ready to get
back to work i would say before i
probably did about 50 50 child care at
about 50 percent my other placements
right now we're at about 80 percent
child care cook specializes in a higher
caliber level of child care with
specific screenings licenses and
training and charges 20 to 30 dollars an
hour anna tolmak has a two-year-old and
a newborn with her hectic schedule she's
thankful for the full-time help nannies
and grannies has given her so in my case
we needed a specific language
requirement not as exhausted
and it's just been game changing and
paying the price is doable thanks to
programs like these what's really
popular is
sharing sitters
back out live natties and grannies is
currently hiring they are providing
part-time options and opportunities as
well and aside from taking care of your
children they also clean cook and even
provide transportation for all of that
information and much more visit our
website eightnewsnow.com reporting live
sally jaramillo live local now